lorsque le premier ministre ma question
est simple
que comptez vous faire maintenant vous
rira dis qu'est l'islam politique et
rétablir l'autorité et la fermeté dans
notre patrie que se passe-t-il chez
angie l'un de nos fleurons industriels
français
quelle est la position de notre pays
dans cette négociation est essentielle
pour l'avenir de la pêche française
obtenir les questions au gouvernement
sur l'antenne de cette exclusivité
c'était un long combat que tous les
présidents de lcp ont essayé de gagner
les questions au gouvernement c'est le
rendez vous hebdomadaire ou l'aller on
se fait connaître en posant une question
ma question est très simple
êtes vous favorable à une majoration de
la cotisation de solidarité pour les
très hauts revenus
c'est aussi un rendez-vous bien peu
théâtral l'élégance de votre question
n'a d'égal que l'inexactitude des propos
que vous y tenez madame ministre
l'euphémisation de votre réponse ne
cache pas la brutalité de votre méthode
les avocats savent lire ils ont très
bien compris mais derrière il ya
toujours de vrais débats politiques le
pouvoir d'achat s'est il amélioré non la
compétitivité at elle explose et non le
chômage at il chuté
non il y avait quand même un paradoxe
c'est que la chaîne qui est dédié à
l'actualité parlementaire se voyait
privé du programme qui était le plus
emblématique du travail parlementaire
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
il y avait une crainte chez les députés
que si on changeait de l'a3 à -cp
et beaucoup de gens qui cesse de
regarder les questions au gouvernement
hors france 3 en fait c'était l'intérêt
aussi puisque les questions au
gouvernement c'était une obligation pour
eux qui tombait un petit peu comme un
pavé au milieu de leur programme de
l'après midi
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
questions d'actualité à 2h30 de direct
consacré à l'actualité politique et
parlementaire à 15h vous vivrez en
direct les questions au gouvernement
l'intérêt de cette exclusivité ce pas
uniquement de dire on est les seuls à
l'avoir c'est avoir deux caméras dans
l'hémicycle en plus des caméras
l'assemblée nous serons en duplex de la
salle des quatre colonnes avec stéphanie
des pierres et clément méric et plus
nous serons au plus près des députés
dans l'hémicycle et ce sera ravie cas
que nous allons retrouver dans un
instant questions au gouvernement pour
lcp c'est un gros bloc d'audience
et c'est aussi une porte d'entrée pour
démontrer tout ce qui est fait autour et
après de pouvoir renvoyer sur les autres
programmes de la chaîne et c'est pour ça
que c'était déterminant pour lcp
d'obtenir cette liberté éditoriale cette
exclusivité sur les questions
gouvernement
[Musique]